le rapport du bureau d'audiences
publiques sur l'environnement sur le
projet de construction d'un tramway à
québec a eu l'effet d'une bombe cette
semaine le bape conseils au gouvernement
de ne pas autoriser le projet en l'état
avec nous ce soir fanny tremblay racicot
professeur à l'école nationale
d'administration publique spécialiste en
transport urbain et yvon charest
président du conseil de l'organisme j'ai
ma passe et ancien pdg de l'industrielle
alliance également à vous de bonsoir
bonsoir madame tremblay ainsi qu'aux
d'abord est ce que le bape a raison de
recommander de ne pas autoriser ce
projet est de demander une révision de
l'étude du projet oui je crois que le
bape a raison c'est ce que moi même
j'avais recommandé pour trois raisons
principales de 1 le tracé qui
sous-optimale de deux la non intégration
avec l'aménagement du territoire et
l'urbanisme est aussi une considération
importante c'est l'accroissement la
capacité routière qui venait avec ce
projet là donc il y avait également
d'autres éléments qui font en sorte que
ce projet ne tient pas la route et
diminue son efficacité et doit être revu
le bape recommande de le conserver mais
de le réviser avant que ça passe en
phase de réalisation
ce qu'a demandé d'ailleurs le ministre
bonnardel parce qu'il veut davantage que
ça touche les banlieues qu'est ce que
vous pensez des conclusions du bape yvon
charest je pense absolument pas la même
chose parce qu'écouter onu cette
consultation dans les 15 dernières
années
alors à chaque consultation le projet
s'est précisée de plus en plus et aux
audiences du bape
cette année quatre fois plus de mémoire
était favorable que défavorable alors le
consensus est développé dans les 15
dernières années est à mon avis ça veut
dire que le projet est mieux au poil et
de là bas mais quand on additionne le
nombre de mémoires en faveur loeb qu'on
dit qu'il ya des gens qui sont en faveur
est ce que parce qu'on additionne des
mémoires qui sont en faveur on a ride
nécessairement la conclusion qu'il faut
absolument approuvé le projet fini
traverse co pas nécessairement jeudi rcc
le fond qu'il importe sur la quantité de
mémoire qui ont été déposés là
avi le bape selon moi soumis un rapport
qui était qui était approfondie que qui
y avait un ensemble de constats et davy
analyser le projet en fonction de la loi
sur le développement durable à écouter
les préoccupations citoyennes et il faut
rappeler aussi que le projet a été
considérablement modifié
donc entre le projet qui était déposée
en 2017 et le projet qui a été révisée
un mois avant le début des audiences du
bape tient une modification importante
qui étaient apportées c'est le retrait
du trambus sur lakeshore et le retrait
des deux remontées mécaniques l'abandon
de toute la requalification de chars et
ouest est le fait qu on ait remplacé sa
part un tas d'infos à midi todd dans le
secteur légende avec tous les détails le
jeu pour qu'on entre trop dans les
détails mais moi je ce que je veux
comprendre
d'ici là c'est quand on nous dit qu il
ne dessert pas assez les banlieues par
exemple et qu'on atteindra pas monsieur
charest les objectifs qui sont ceux de
favoriser véritablement être transfert
de l'automobile au transfert au
transport collectif c'est ce que dit le
bape est ce qu'on n'est pas sur un
constat fondamentale non c'est bien une
femme que tu fais lyon c'est que dans la
région de québec à seulement 10 % des
gens qui prennent le transport en commun
alors subitement les gens voudraient
compose de aucun réseau structurant à un
service total pour tout le monde et
malheureusement avec un budget de 3
points 1 milliards font commencer par la
colonne vertébrale et c'est pour ça
qu'on a laissé tomber le tram bus donc
la colonne vertébrale vont relier les
pôles de déplacement des plus importants
et à court terme ça veut dire que les
gens qui sont en banlieue vont faire un
rabattement sur cette colonne vertébrale
et géante la deuxième phase par la
troisième phase où on va pouvoir faire
comme morial comme bordeaux
comme bien des villes et étendre le
service à plus de gens donc je conviens
vidéo pour histoire 3.1 milliards
seraient pas tout faire seul la première
la première batterie ok ce que vous
dites c'est que c'est une première
bouchée c'est une phase 1 est donc la
phase on ne peut pas atteindre
totalement tous les objectifs qui
seraient ceux d'un
justement à faire un véritable transfert
de l'automobile vers le transport
collectif exactement bon madame 30 dire
ce que vous en pensez quoi
j'en pense que les banlieues raid du
doivent être desservis de manière
prioritaire parce que le problème à
québec c'est qu' il n'y a pas de
services adéquats dans les banlieues qui
se trouve sur le territoire de
l'agglomération actuellement
donc je te que je crois que si une
intervention prioritaire à faire ce
serait de desservir les endroits qui
n'ont pas de service efficace
d'abord et avant tout pour ensuite
consolidé avec des modes plus plus lourd
plus rapide parce que la croissance
démographique a été vers les banlieues
parce que comme le dit le bape la grande
région de québec est vraiment une région
abonnés à l'auto l'appui vous l'avez dit
monsieur charest donc dans les
circonstances un réseau structurant puis
un tramway doit déjà atteindre une
majorité de banlieue justement pour
qu'il y ait des gens dans ce transport
collectif le plus important c'est que
tant qu'on faire bien
si on fait une autre consultation
l'étalement urbain et votre simplement
continuer pour n'aura aucun contrôle si
au moins on réussit à apposer une
colonne vertébrale peu de gens
connaissent le début de la fin ben là ça
va influencer des constructions partir
de maintenant et c'est pour ça qu'il ya
déjà un point 5 milliards
d'investissements immobiliers possibles
le long du tracé
les gens attendent seulement le goût du
gouvernement alors c'est en 1.5
milliards $ d'investissements
immobiliers
c'est lui qui va arrêter d'étalement
urbain mais si vous faites un autre
homme de consultation l'étalement urbain
va continuer et juste pour vous dire
mais mon adjointe administrative quand
j'ai commencé à travailler pour moi à
partir de chez elle sa réussite de 8
heures le matin
oui il en parle c'est quand le pris sa
retraite
la pâte à 18h45 oui prenez aucune
décision de transport en commun donc
l'étalement vont continuer est-ce qu'en
proposant de ne pas autoriser le projet
fait ni trembler récit qu est-ce qu on
ne risque pas de jeter le bébé avec
l'eau du bain
et de ne pas avoir de projet de
transport structure je croirais pas je
crois que ça prend ça prend un peu d' un
pas de recul pour faire la part des
choses puis aller avec un projet qui
soit véritablement efficace non c'est
pas nécessairement bénéficia bhl pour
pour le transport collectif qui est
d'avoir un projet qui tiennent pas la
route piétons je pense est inconvenant
c'est peut-être pas nécessaire de
prendre quelques années encore mais je
pense qu'on peut d'abord apporté des
modifications au projet qui est mineur
au projet qui est sur la table
chose qui n'a pas été fait pendant les
phases de la consultation et de revoir
le c'est surtout le réseau d'autobus
lucky qui tient pas la route et le tracé
du tramway également certaines sections
mais je pense pas que je pense que
l'argument du temps et des années c'est
juste un argument pour maintenir ce
qu'on a actuellement mais il ya
peut-être moyen de faire des choses de
manière plus rapide et je suis fillon
monsieur fillion moi je me fie à la
sagesse collective
aujourd'hui les acteurs économiques
principaux la chambre de commerce le
seum le conseil du patronat
une grande proportion de bonnes
conditions financières et de compagnies
d'assurances ont dit au gouvernement le
projet mur merci de passer de décret
avant noël pour qu'enfin on énerve que
l'on devra quoi ça sert le bac monsieur
charest le scotch comprend de toutes les
pressions qui existe elle est lobé mais
il ya un bape qui arrive à 600 pages de
rapports et qui arrive à une conclusion
alors vous avez tout à fait raison la
question est la suivante c'est que le
l'objectif du bape
c'est le fameux concept une consultation
citoyenne et je suis heureux qu'ils ont
entendu le truqueur sur le fait qu'il
fallait sauver les arbres et c'est pour
ça que la ville de québec et
l'université laval hongrie cette semaine
une chaire sur la bourbince mais ma
question est la suivante c'est quand il
ya du jeu cette consultation que
quelqu'un décide d'en faire une huitième
il y aura bien un intérêt à préciser
pourquoi nous fin de huitième et quel
est l'objectif poursuivi
parce que moi j'ai regardé le mandat des
trois commissaires puis le mandat c'est
est d'analyser les size l1
de développement durable comme s'il n'y
avait jamais eu de consultation bondam
tremblay racicot là dessus en réponse
dernier madame tremblay ratio est en
fait le problème c'est que l'épreuve le
projet était mal ficelé dès le départ a
été précipité on était politisé c'est ce
qui amène ou comme ça à prendre acte que
ce projet ne soit pas prêt à aller en
phase de réalisation
donc on n'a pas de recul pour avoir un
projet qui tient la route bon on verra
de toute façon la suite des choses le
gouvernement a demandé des améliorations
à la ville de québec monsieur charest
madame tremblay rasco merci d'avoir été
avec nous ce soir
un grand merci à vous merci